I think it's a wonderful idea I mean why
not they've made great production
choices so far so it could only be a
good thing I imagine you're looking at
the same kind of thing that happened
with something like Star Trek on you
know you go from small screen to the big
screen with with relative ease about
your film I think that makes sense I
think you can only carry on this for a
while in series when and then eventually
when you start to wrap things up you
need to make it really epic and huge and
I think a movie would be a perfect
perfect place for that I think it's a
great idea and you know what 94 the
reasons that George said a lot of what
he was talking about was budgetary I was
saying you know that from where he wants
the story to go you know the TV budgets
not really going to cut it and then
you've got it you've got to do a story
like that justice and I think and so the
kind of budget that a movie would allow
in a movie or three would be it would be
great it's a really difficult thing
because it's like every episode is a
movie in itself so I don't know what
more they could do by specifically
making a movie or be a really
interesting concept to think about I
think it's very fitting for such a big
project to end and the silver screen if
that's what was to happen the final few
books to read all sorts of rivers and
stuff I don't think you're going to get
as much attention to detail which is
what a lot of Game of Thrones is about
if you're in a movie that's just simply
not enough enough time and I'm speaking
for myself when I go into movies I don't
like movies being too long if I if I see
a three and a half hour movie I come out
more sort of fed up but that's how much
I spent in that I'd liked it to be sort
of fairly concise and so you don't want
to lose that with with roads you want to
keep it - as long winded as possible so
you can enjoy all those moments the
serialization and the sort of you know
length of time it takes to tell each
sees and allows you to develop a
narrative in a way that you could never
do with the film so I think if they did
the film's it would probably have to
work a little bit
like the Star Wars films or something
where they're where the films themselves
are like chapters in a way so I don't
imagine you could do a lot with one film
you know or you'd have to be very have
to be very specific to the little moment
I would love to see a game of Thrones
film I just I think it would have to be
almost like the end of the series it
would be like you would encapsulate in
one film the movie should be about
Khyber
Qyburn the movie and then Qyburn to
return of Qyburn there's so much of the
books there yeah it's mentioned but
doesn't have the same depth that George
Gibson in print so anything like that
would be fabulous I think it would suit
I think it would suit big scale single
productions very very well I feel like
you haven't finished with the TV series
yet and also the beauty of television
which we're all learning now is that you
really can give space and you can build
on characters you can make them
contradict themselves
bring it on TV it's just gonna be like a
super super super big episode isn't it
they do they're less structured very
carefully and it's a major major bit of
storytelling I love it you know bring it
on I can't wait I just can't like make a
very good job of it but this serial form
is wonderful I mean how many hours of it
if we had so far we're just about to
start shooting series 5 in June and I
see no reason why I shouldn't go to 6
and 7 we've got that great spread of the
whole story
they'll make a good film of it they make
a filmer they can't be longer than two
hour and two and a half hours maybe they
could obviously spend a lot more money
and then who knows more dragons at set
more dragons I'm all up for the movie
cuz it means more dragons yes and if
we're looking at a war between fire and
ice the best place to do it is on the
big screen possibly in 3d I just saw
Godzilla which was like the fire between
fire you know the fight between fire and
ice in a way it was just massive huge so
you know if you're doing something big
like that you want to see it on a big
screen so I think it's it's a good place
to go I think it'd be a great way to
it's a round off pretty amazing story